respecting the will of the British
people we all recognized that the
process of all the exit was in
everyone's and especially in the UK's
interest our discussions were calm and
measured we do understand that some time
is now needed to allow the dust to
settle in the UK but they also expect
the intentions of the UK government to
be specified as soon as possible this
was a very clear message which I believe
Prime Minister Cameron will take back to
London we also consider the post brexit
economic situation of the presence of
the ECB president who we are showed us
about the good and constant cooperation
of central banks however it was also
made clear that breaks it means
substantially lower growth in the UK
with a possible negative spillover all
over the world let me first say a few
words on the outcome of the bridge
referendum which obviously is very
disappointing for for all of us at the
same time it's now effect so we have to
deal with this fact and I do believe we
need to work quickly but also in a way
that ensures stability the first step
now obviously is for the British
government to invoke this article 50 but
we have to accept that the negotiations
will be time consuming bill be complex
and I hope will be done an amicable
atmosphere our partners in the European
Union are genuinely sad that we are
planning to leave this organization and
that was very much the tone of the
discussions at the dinner tonight while
we seek the best possible partnership
that we can after leaving the European
Union it is impossible to have all of
the benefits of membership without some
of the costs of membership that's
something the next British government is
going to have to think through very
carefully Britain will be leaving the
European Union but we will not be
turning our back
on Europe these are our friends our
allies and partners we have a huge
amount in common with each other in
terms of the values of democracy and
freedom and human rights and wanting to
see progress and sharing the challenges
that we face as European nations